el expresidente de honduras juan orlando
hernández se encuentra en custodia
policial en tegucigalpa este martes se
entregó a las autoridades tras el pedido
de extradición por parte de estados
unidos que la acusa de narcotráfico y de
otros dos cargos relacionados se espera
que hoy hernández comparezca ante un
juez designado por el supremo para así
estudiar la solicitud de extradición y
será él quienes determine los procesos a
seguir en este caso recordemos que el 27
de enero pasado hernández concluyó ocho
años de su mandato
por su parte la justicia estadounidense
estudiaba vistosas del ex presidente con
el narcotráfico luego de que su hermano
fuera condenado en la ciudad de nueva
york por los mismos delitos el ex
mandatario podría llegar a eeuu en un
plazo de tres meses donde sería
finalmente juzgada para ello quiero
saludar en este momento a otto rené a
guetta ramírez él es historiador y
doctor en ciencia política gracias a
otro por estar con nosotros en ese
espacio de france24 directo américa le
pregunto principalmente cómo opera el
narcotráfico en honduras y cuál es el
papel de juan orlando hernández en toda
esta trama
hola muy buenos días pero honduras desde
hace ya tres años ha sido uno de los
países de tránsito y almacenamiento de
droga más importantes de la región y
estamos hablando que este rol en la
cadena del narcotráfico que inicia en
colombia venezuela y se extiende a eeuu
ha sido así desde ya desde los años 90
ian watson 90 ya honduras tenía una
presencia muy fuerte de narcotráfico con
narcotraficantes y fueron muy
importantes en la región en los años 90
y que fueron extraditados también y que
dejaron sentar las bases de el negocio
igual del narcotráfico
sin embargo hay que recordar que este
ese tipo de negocios evoluciona y
evoluciona en la medida en que los
estados
le permiten una evolución en ese sentido
y claramente el estado de honduras ha
sido por supuesto también un estado
sumamente frágil sumamente débil con
procesos de democratización que fueron
muy limitados y que también con extensas
regiones del país sin presencia del
estado con unas fuerzas armadas las
fuerzas de seguridad sumamente frágiles
y con una clase política que lógicamente
estuvo una encontró una oportunidad muy
grande de grecia de mandar por tráfico
desde como repito los años 80 y 90
eso es digamos el contexto general
orlando hernández crece y evoluciona en
ese orden de ideas estamos hablando de
un narcotráfico patrocinado por el
estado le quiero preguntar digamos en
ese contexto que usted daba que tan
difícil es llegar al poder en estos
países específicamente hablemos en este
caso de honduras que es tan difícil
llegar a este poder y no puedes estar
salpicado por el narcotráfico no estar
ya inmerso en todo este entramado de
narcotráfico y corrupción puede llegar
un presidente de estar totalmente
alejado y ajeno a esto también a lo
mejor no estar inmerso pero hay
presidentes o mandatarios que se hacen
la vista gorda porque pues así funcionan
las cosas y así lamentablemente lo
tienen que hacer que realmente pasa en
esos países otros
es muy difícil que un político y el remo
desde un presidente hasta un alcalde
municipal esté completamente libre de la
influencia del narcotráfico lo que varía
definitivamente es la intensidad la
exposición y los mecanismos a través de
los cuales la influencia del
narcotráfico llega a beneficiarlo a
presionarlo y lógicamente en busca su
sector se dan
hay que recordar que los los políticos
no necesariamente tienen que tocar la
cocaína para estar para estar
influenciados por el narcotráfico esto
ocurre a través de inversiones a través
de negocios a través de financiamiento
de campañas políticas a través de
influencia de otros actores políticos
que están inmersos en sus campañas en el
caso de hernández lógicamente es un caso
sumamente expuesto es un caso
escandaloso por el hecho de que estuvo
él involucrado directamente junto con su
hermano puntocom y otros miembros de su
familia entonces digamos es un caso
descarado en el sentido de que no hubo
ninguna tenemos una limitación en hacer
evidente el hecho que estaban inmersos
en el tráfico y eso es lo que puso en
claro los puntos en nueva york y el
hecho de que si bien es cierto aquí
honduras mucha gente lo sabía mucha
gente era consciente de eso el nivel de
exposición que demostró el caso que fue
llevado por los vicios mayor paso otras
hermanas de sus miembros de sus partidos
del gobierno es evidente digamos el
nivel de unidad con el cual actuaron que
los expuso el mismo hay algo que tampoco
entonces me queda muy claro otro porque
pues teniendo en cuenta que ya su
hermano fue condenado y juzgado en nueva
york por narcotráfico
posiblemente pudiera tener pues relación
con su hermano hablamos el expresidente
juan orlando hernández que está ya en el
ojo del huracán ahora hablemos el papel
de eeuu porque washington sabiendo que
hernández podría estar involucrado en
todos estos casos permitió durante los
ocho años de su mandato que fuera uno de
sus principales aliados en términos de
migración y también incluso de luz de
lucha contra el narcotráfico y crimen
organizado
eso es parte de la política de eeuu que
es muy común digamos el hecho de que
eeuu establece alianzas estratégicas con
políticos que
si bien es cierto son colaboradores de
algunos temas específicos de interés de
su política exterior en el caso de los
barrios centroamericanos veamos
migración y narcotráfico
necesitan tolerar por decirlo de alguna
manera ciertas cosas que saben
perfectamente bien que no son las
correctas estamos hablando desde
negocios ilícitos hasta conductas
antidemocráticas este patrón lo hemos
visto por repetido en méxico en
centroamérica en colombia y en otros
países de américa latina y tenemos otras
regiones del mundo entonces
digamos que se colabora se apoya y eso
fue muy evidente en el año 2017 cuando
cuando orlando se reeligió de manera
completamente ilegal y sin embargo pues
tuvo el aval de eeuu a pesar de una
protesta masiva en el país y numerosas
violaciones a derechos humanos sin
embargo si se celebra digamos eso fue
muy fuerte durante el gobierno de donald
trump se celebro muchísimo la
colaboración de parte de formar la
interfaz de sistema de inmigración en la
lucha contra el narcotráfico e incluso
en lo puso donaldson como ejemplo de la
gestión de la pandemia
sin embargo pues aquí están las
consecuencias
años después tiempo después otra
administración de eeuu unos intereses
pues diferentes en la forma de hacer las
cosas y revela esto
y algo que todo mundo se dice es ya lo
sabías parte los interrogantes bueno
mucho tiene que ver con el hecho que era
un presidente y entonces hay un cálculo
del impacto que implica extra dictar un
presidente dar un golpe a la labor de
habilidad de un país sin que eso en
países tan frágiles constituciones tan
débiles pues no se es no genera en una
crisis de gobernabilidad masiva claro
pero bueno ya y estamos viendo las
consecuencias dos semanas después ya la
justicia estadounidense hizo lo propio
pues también ya acusándolo de estos
vínculos con el narcotráfico de cocaína
específicamente y también de armas de
fuego gracias auto por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
y analizar todo ese entramado
narcotráfico y corrupción que
lamentablemente siempre salpica a los
países de nuestra región hablamos de
américa latina y el caribe gracias otro
un placer lo tolero